PRESENTER: Hello.
Welcome to Google Los Angeles.
And for those of you watching
on our Talks at Google
channel, welcome.
We're very pleased to welcome
Jeff Potter, author of
"Cooking for Geeks," who will
be running some experiments
today that will involve
all of you.
A little bit about Jeff.
Jeff's background is computer
science and art.
He's working as a software
engineer, or has worked as a
software engineer, and--
JEFF POTTER: Still am.
PRESENTER: Still are.
And is currently working for a
startup, which I learned is
based here in West Hollywood,
or the LA area, even though
Jeff lives on the East Coast.
He'll tell us a bit more
about the connection
between geeks and food.
But I'll hand the floor over
to him, and I ask you to
please welcome Jeff Potter.
[APPLAUSE]
JEFF POTTER: So thanks so
much for that very kind
introduction.
So yeah.
My background is computer
science, and I ended up
writing this book a few years
ago after being at
one of the Foo Camps.
Not food, but Foo,
as in O'Reilly.
And one thing led to another,
and here I am, still geeking
out over food and having
a good time with it.
So today, I'm going to
really talk about
two different things.
The first half of this is going
to be basic food models,
and the second half is
going to involve that
tray in front of you.
So when it comes to food, it's
always fun to ask people what
they think happens
when they cook.
So given a lump of cookie dough,
you put in your oven,
what happens?
You get fatter.
That is perhaps true.
What else happens?
AUDIENCE: Heat it applied to
it and it changes the--
AUDIENCE: There's a change
in molecular structure.
JEFF POTTER: Heat is applied
to it, and the molecular
structure changes
a little bit.
Definitely something happens.
I've had people say magic, but
there's a little bit more
going on here than just cookie
going from raw dough to
magically baked cookie.
So the thing I love about
doing this particular
experiment is you can do this
at home with a probe
thermometer really easy.
There's actually a little white
line on the left there.
That's a probe that I stuck into
a lump of cookie dough,
threw it into an oven, and just
started watching what
happened to the internal
temperature as
it started to bake.
And around 92 degrees
Fahrenheit,
this begins to happen.
The edge of it begins to
kind of spread out.
And this also is the temperature
at which butter
begins to melt.
So that's actually kind
of insightful.
You begin to think about the
fact that the food is heating
up, and certain reactions
are occurring.
In this case, butter
is melting.
Then a little bit higher up,
around 212 degrees, the
moisture from the butter and the
egg in it begin to steam
out and obviously evaporate.
But also, certain starches in
the flours begin to actually
melt and change their
structure as well.
A little bit hotter, around
310 degrees, the outside
begins to start turning
light brown.
Any guesses as to what's
happening at this temperature?
AUDIENCE: The sugar
is burning.
AUDIENCE: Carmelization.
JEFF POTTER: Caramelization.
It's actually a good guess, but
it's not actually what's
going on here.
This is the Maillard
reaction, which
begins around 300 degrees.
The Maillard reaction
is a breakdown of
proteins and sugars.
Basically the proteins and the
sugars combine and then break
and form hundreds of compounds,
some of which are
brown, some of which taste
really good, and some of
which, unfortunately,
cause cancer.
And then a little bit hotter,
continuing on the cookie ride
here, around 350, 360 degrees,
this is where caramelization
of sucrose begins to really
noticeably occur.
Now, with both of these
temperatures, they're
[INAUDIBLE]
reactions, so it's not like the
water temperature, where
at 212, without anything
else in that water,
it begins to boil.
These reactions kind of pick up
slowly over time, and the
hotter it gets, the
more quickly those
reactions will occur.
So here's the nice little
visual proof of this.
This is just a batch of sugar
cookie dough that you just
bake at various different
temperatures.
And you can actually see there's
this kind of distinct
point between that 325 degree
temperature and that 375
degree temperature where the
outside of that cookie begins
to really turn brown
pretty quickly.
So this is a little more
complicated model than maybe
you had a minute ago about
cookies making you fat or
going through molecular
changes.
But it's useful, because you now
know how to set your oven.
You now know if you want those
nice, brown reactions on the
outside, that your environment
has to be at these
temperatures and be this hot for
those reactions to occur.
And if you don't want those
reactions, you now know you
need to make sure your
environment does
not get that hot.
So what does this have to do
with three dead white guys?
In this case, it's Aristotle,
Newton, and Einstein.
And all three of these people
came up with theories and
models about how
gravity works.
Now, the original model,
Aristotle's, was
really pretty basic.
It just said, things
like to go to their
natural resting place.
Simple model, but it gives you
some predictive power.
Same way you get up to Newton
and Galileo, and they came up
with this set of equations that
are still taught in high
school physics today
about gravity.
But famously, those sets of
equations don't work for
predicting things like Mercury's
orbit around the sun
or for GPS calculations.
You really have to get into an
even more advanced model-- in
this case, Einstein's theory
of general relativity--
to get a model that's actually
predictive enough to be useful
for those cases.
So the point here is that you
get better models, you get
better predictions.
Now, they're also more
complicated models.
The second part of thinking
about science, whether in the
kitchen or elsewhere, is really
understanding that
science relies on both
data and theory.
So you can have a bunch of
equations, but without some
data to actually back it up, you
don't really know if those
equations are particularly
predictive.
And on the flip side of the
pile of data, without any
equations or model to kind of
explain what the general thing
is happening there, it's
just the pile of data.
This is definitely
true in cooking.
The example I gave you with the
cookie dough was empirical
data gathered with the probe
thermometer, but there are
equations in food as well.
This is how to tell when your
meat is done cooking.
I confess, I don't know
how to read this.
I do know it's a tensor equation
with four different
variables, and I figure there's
somebody here who can
explain this to me.
Come up afterward.
Let me know.
But for me, it really is much
more about the empirical side,
which kind of makes
the cooking fun.
Because you can go into the
kitchen and think about what's
going on here.
What's the model?
What's happening?
And a half hour later, gather
enough empirical data to kind
of fit to see if it actually
makes sense with what you're
thinking or if you can reject
your hypothesis.
So I'm going to run through a
couple different models over
the next 10, 15 minutes and
kind of give you a simple
version and then a more
complicated version, so
hopefully that the next time you
go into your kitchen, you
can think to yourself, hey,
what's going on here?
How can make this better?
So in the case of meat, what
happens when you cook meat?
There's various levels of
doneness, everything from rare
to well done.
Most people actually prefer
their meat medium rare,
although there are some cultural
biases if you grew up
in the Midwest and have older
populations in the Midwest,
they'll prefer their meat
more well done.
But in general, people
prefer the texture
of medium rare meat.
This comes down to actually
different protein structures
in that meat going through
different reactions at
different points when
you cook them.
So when you think about cooking
a piece of steak--
in this case, it's just a steak
tip that I dropped onto
a really hot cast iron pan--
you can see there's this
gradient of doneness, and the
middle of this is completely
rare, and the outside--
well, the outside,
you can actually
see, is kind of brown.
That lets you know that that's
the Maillard reaction-- the
proteins in the meat and
some of the sugars--
breaking down and
turning brown.
So you know that the outside of
this meat actually got up
above that 310, 320 degree
temperature.
So in that meat, when it cooks,
different proteins are
going to denature and change
their structure, change their
texture, and basically cook
at various different
temperatures.
And there's really two proteins
that seem to be
responsible for this.
In the case of something like
steak tip, it's going to be
myosin and actin, and we happen
to prefer meats where
one of these--
myosin--
is actually cooked and
denatured, and the actin is
actually still in its
native structure.
There's about maybe a 10 to
20 degree window where
this seems to occur.
It's between 130 to 150 degrees
Fahrenheit that these
temperature ranges really end
up being ideal for getting
that right texture that people
generally prefer.
Now, if you look at other cuts
of meat, there is another
molecule, another kind of
protein that comes into play.
Any guesses as to what
this would be?
This is collagen.
It's essentially the equivalent
of steel and concrete.
It gives the muscle
tissue structure.
It's almost like
reinforcement.
If you think about animals like
octopus and squid, they
don't really have a skeletal
structure.
They have a lot of collagen,
and that's what gives them
their structure.
Which also, when it comes to
cooking, makes it tough.
So if you think of something
like calamari, where you cook
it and it's tough, it's because
this particular
protein is in a state
that, well, is
technically like a rubber.
And in fact, if you talk to a
material scientist, they'll
tell you it is a rubber.
Collagen itself, when it
breaks down, is kind of
fascinating.
It's this triple helix structure
that's got lots of
different bonds holding
the three different
twisted bits together.
And in its native structure
like this, it's actually
pretty tender.
When it begins to unwind, the
cross links between the
different helixes are still
holding it intact, and it's
like a rubber at that point.
And if you cook it even longer,
it will then hydrolyze
and completely break down
into little chunks.
So if you think about squid, you
can either cook it really
quickly or for a really
long time.
But if you get it somewhere in
the middle, it'll be in this
middle state where it's
denatured, but not actually
hydrolyzed, and that
makes it tough.
So if you're cooking something
like short ribs or a duck leg,
and it's tough, the
secret to it is
actually to cook it longer--
long enough to let it break
down that protein.
So this is a really easy
proof of this.
Grab some short ribs, grab some
barbecue sauce, throw it
in a slow cooker, and if you
come back two or three hours
later, it'll be at
temperature.
The myosin and actin will have
gone through their reactions,
but the actual collagen, which
is a much tougher molecule to
actually go through the chemical
process of breaking
down, will still be
basically tough.
So throw it in, cover it up with
some sauce, come back a
few hours later, and you'll
actually have, if you wait
long enough, an amazing, really
tender beef short rib.
So here's a simple model, and
here's the better model.
The simple model is, well,
follow a recipe.
Cook it to 165.
The better model says, hey,
think about what kind
of meat this is.
Is it high in collagen?
Well then, you probably need to
cook it in a cooking method
that either keeps that collagen
native and not
denatured at all, in which case,
really fast cooking,
high heat, or you need
to cook it for a long
time to break it down.
And if it's a low collagen cut
of meat, well, make sure you
think about the myosin and the
actin and the temperature
ranges that you're
trying to hit.
Why 165?
Everyone kind of has
heard this forever.
Make sure your chicken or your
turkey is cooked to 165.
AUDIENCE: Kill the bacteria.
JEFF POTTER: Kill
the bacteria.
Yeah.
These guys are not fun.
But unfortunately, the 165
point is higher than the
temperature point at which the
myosin protein is denatured.
So now you have this
tough problem.
You can either have it be
literally tough, because the
myosins denature and change the
texture, or you can have
it be cold enough, but
potentially have a
problem with this.
This is salmonella.
Bacillus cereus is actually the
highest common pathogen
that is found in food.
It actually doesn't really live
much above 122 degrees,
but of course, you can be
exposed to high temperatures
for a short period of time and
still manage to survive.
Same thing with some
of these guys.
So the standard rule that's
actually given in food safety
stuff is something called the
danger zone rule, and it says,
don't hold foods between 40 and
140 for more than two to
four hours.
It actually depends on what
state you live in.
The guidelines for Food Safety
are state by state.
I'm not sure about California,
but back on the East Coast, I
think it's two hours
where I am.
So why 140 degrees if the
highest temperature that we
know from Bacillus cereus
is around 122?
It has a lot to do with the
time at temperature, which
we'll get into in
a little bit.
Now, you don't have to take
my word for that 140
degree being OK.
This is actually from the Food
Safety Inspectual Services
division of the USDA.
They publish charts that say,
hey, if you hold this piece of
turkey or chicken at this
temperature for this length of
time, it's sufficiently
pasteurized to be safe.
So this is really actually a
fascinating thing, because it
means you don't have to cook
your food to 165 if you hold
your food at whatever
temperature for long enough.
So a little more of a
complicated model.
The complicated model is,
hey, cook it to 165.
This is basically the instant
kill temperature.
At this point, anything that's
there is going to be dead.
But if you want to get a better
texture and really
think about it, then you need
to hold it at time at
temperature and properly
pasteurize it.
Eggs.
Eggs are fascinating.
Eggs are actually one of the
best ways to think about food
science, and I can geek out over
them for quite a while.
There's dozens of different
proteins in eggs, and there's
this really, really narrow
range between 144 and 158
where eggs are cooked, but not
hard boiled overcooked.
And when you throw an egg into
a pot of boiling water, it's
basically going to follow that
blue line in terms of its
internal temperature.
The blue line is
kind of simple.
There's actually some step
functions where different
proteins absorb heat and energy,
and it kind of pauses.
But work with me here.
This is the general idea.
You put an egg into boiling
water, it comes from fridge
temperature, and eventually
reaches that too hot
temperature.
So what we do is we pull
it out at some point.
We go, hey, I'm going to
poach this egg for
five to seven minutes.
You pull it out, and there's a
little bit of carryover as the
outside of the egg is hotter,
and the heat kind of
penetrates in towards
the center.
But hopefully, you hit it
right, and you get your
perfect egg.
But what would you do if you
want to cook a perfect egg?
This is an egg cooked
for two minutes.
Definitely not cooked.
Three minutes, four minutes,
five minutes.
At six or seven minutes, maybe
it's a little bit runny.
Around eight minutes,
that looks like a
pretty good egg to me.
I personally would
go for that.
You might get a little bit
more well cooked, and
eventually, around, in this
case, 11 minutes, it's a
sufficiently hard boiled egg.
But what we're really going
for is something that's in
that ideal range.
Something that's got the right
texture, where the right
proteins are denatured and
cooked, and the other ones
above that aren't actually
set yet.
And there is a way to do this.
And when you do this, you get an
egg that actually has this
amazing texture, where the white
and the yolk are kind of
roughly the same texture, and
you can take the egg and just
crack it, and it kind of falls
out of the shell like that,
which is amazing when you're
cooking brunch for like 100
people, or doing a demo for 100
people who have eggs in
front of them that might
be cooked this way.
And as I said, you get
an egg where the
texture is kind of amazing--
where the yolk and the white
are just set in a way that,
after dozens of years of eating
eggs, it's like, wow, a
new way to cook an egg.
Who would have thought?
So this is done via a technique
called sous vide,
which is a horrible name.
It means under vacuum in French,
which refers to one
step when you're cooking
other food this way.
Really, it's ultra precise,
low temperature poaching.
In this case, there's actually
one of these water baths set
up around the corner for you
guys to look at afterward.
All it is is a water heater with
a little agitator that
keeps the water moving around
and a thermostat and
controller that keeps the
water at a very precise
temperature.
So if you think about that
graph, where I said there was
that really, really narrow
range, this basically keeps
the water at that range.
So there's commercial equipment
to do this.
Lab equipment.
This is $1,000 territory.
I bought mine on eBay.
Who knows?
I hope it was clean.
There's consumer stuff,
$400-ish.
It matches the rest of
your stainless steel
appliance, and it's nice.
You plug in, and it works.
If you're handy, a pair of
wire cutters and a slow
cooker, you too can MacGyver
your own set up
for less than $50.
And there are some amazing
reasons you
might want to do this.
So here's a piece of meat that's
been cooked this way.
You see the piece on the left,
which I showed you a photo of
earlier, where you have that
center being rare, and as you
went to the outside,
it got well done.
And then there's a piece on the
right, which is completely
medium rare, center to edge.
It's just kind of texturally
perfect, the whole thing.
Not this little narrow band,
not the middle-- the whole
thing is just perfect.
You'll also notice that the
outside has no branding
reaction on it.
So you know the outside didn't
get up above that 320ish
degree temperature.
There's no Maillard reaction on
it, which is another clue
that it's actually
cooked this way.
When you do cook this way, by
the way, what you normally do
is separate the two steps of
internal temperature and
external temperature.
You would cook it sous vide,
then you would take it and
drop in the pan for just a few
seconds to get the outside
nice and browned without cooking
it that much further.
So the simple cooking model,
A, cook food for a certain
amount of time.
But the better cooking model
is, hey, think about what
temperature you're trying to
get to, think about the
reactions that occur at those
temperatures, and then figure
out how to get an environment
where the food is going to
come up to that temperature or
down to that temperature in a
controlled way that's safe.
Really, here, though, the key
insight is that temperature is
way more important than time.
Time is just a proxy
for temperature.
So here's a handy dandy chart
of almost everything I just
threw at you in terms
of temperatures.
It's kind of amazing that most
things happen in what's
actually a relatively narrow
range of temperatures.
If you think about wet
cooking methods--
these are things like steaming,
boiling, anything
that really involves water--
they're all things that
happen, obviously, below the
temperature at which water is
able to turn to steam, and those
reactions, those cooking
methods, will not get the
reactions that occur at higher
temperatures on this graph.
So these are better models.
They're not perfect models.
And the reason for this is that,
in theory, the model
describes a perfect world, but
in reality, it's got some sort
of error bar on it.
Our better model's got a smaller
error bar, but it's
still a model, and so take
everything I said with some
small grain of salt, pardon
the food pun.
There are exceptions to all
these rules, but at the same
time, all models are wrong,
some models are useful.
Having a better model at this
point will hopefully help you
when you go into the kitchen
to actually cook something.
So I showed you this
graph a minute ago.
It's always fun to think
about the extremes--
what happens if you
go way, way hot?
Of course, this is where my
background in computer
science comes out.
It's like, well, what happens
if we go this high?
AUDIENCE: Pizza.
JEFF POTTER: Pizza.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Actually, pizza works incredibly
well, because it's
very, very thin, and so you
don't have to wait a very long
for the whole thing to
come to temperature.
This is my old oven back
on the East Coast.
I just followed somebody else's
advice and clipped the
lock so I could open it while
on cleaning cycle.
Let me tell you that 800 degrees
is substantially
different than 700 degrees.
I cannot put my hand into an 800
degree oven for more than
like half a second, maybe.
700 degrees, you can
kind of pick up
the casserole, whatever.
800 degrees is just an
impenetrable wall of hot.
So yeah, you can easily get your
oven up to insanely hot
temperatures, and you can make
amazingly delicious pizza in
like 45 seconds.
It's ridiculous.
The downside of it is your
oven is really not
designed for this.
One of these is the original
pane of glass
on the double wall.
The second piece of material
there is actually something
called Pyroceram III.
It's quartz crystal.
It's what they used to
use on missile nose
cones in the 1950s.
It's heat rated to a much
higher temperature.
My oven broke, basically.
I was putting the pizza in one
day, and a little bit of sauce
fell off the edge of the pizza
and hit the glass, and the
glass basically went
[EXPLOSION NOISE]
and broke.
It's truly amazing what you
can buy on the internet.
And thank you guys for making
it really easy for me to go
and search for Pyroceram
III and get someone
to custom cut it.
And the irony is, it was cheaper
than the replacement
part from the manufacturer
of the oven.
What happens if you go
the other direction?
Ice cream, yeah.
Negative 320 is about the
temperature at which liquid
nitrogen boils.
I will point out that when you
make ice cream this way, you
can make delicious ice cream
that you can't make other
ways, because ethanol doesn't
freeze at standard ice cream
temperatures.
If you get it cold enough, it
does, and there's enough
hysteresis in the system where
once it sets, you can then
bring it back up to
a temperature
that's safe to eat--
around, say, negative
20 Fahrenheit.
It's kind of amazing when you
can do with a little bit of
ingenuity and thinking
about what happens.
Some milk, a bottle of Bailey's,
some sugar, throw
some liquid nitrogen in
it, wait 30 seconds,
and call it a day.
So unfortunately, I don't have
any liquid nitrogen on hand
today to make you guys some
of this ice cream.
Just take my word for it.
It's really delicious.
I think it's page 349
or something.
There are instructions
in the book.
And I'm in LA every couple of
weeks, so if some people
wanted to get together and have
some liquid nitrogen,
this could be done.
It is delicious.
Just make sure it's not too
cold, because you actually
will freeze your mouth,
which is not fun.
The first half of the
talk ends here.
This is the standard, hey, here
are some models of how
stuff works in the kitchen.
Simple models, simple
predictions, better models,
better predictions.
I would say that three key
takeaways, if you really want
to remember these three things,
is temperature is more
important than time.
Think about what the
temperatures are.
310 for Maillard, 350
for caramelization.
Now you know how to set
your oven or pick
your cooking method.
And then finally, don't overcook
and don't undercook
your meats.
Getting the right temperature
is actually really important
to getting really good flavor
and really good texture.
So now we could do the fun
experiments that are in front
of you guys.
And this is the bit that I have
not had the opportunity
to do this way in the past,
because Chef Bill here has
done an amazing job at actually
creating these
wonderful trays which, for
people who are watching
online, I'm terribly sorry.
It's not even really easy to set
this up, because you need
someone else to do it for you.
Otherwise, you know what
the experiments are.
So we've got, I think, four
different things here, and
we're going to start
with the wine one.
So don't actually do any of
these steps until I tell you.
But in the white cup is
this nice blend of
Syrah Merlot, 2011.
It has no description on the
back, but it looks pretty.
Reserve, de--
I'm sorry, I'm not going to try
to butcher French while
being recorded.
And in the small plastic up
is a 2012 that's actually
substantially similar.
And let's see here.
It says on the back, "Philosophy
of farming small
Hillside vineyard sites and
naturally and harmoniously
with nature.
Made from 25 to 50 year old
vines on the sunny and stony
slopes of Languedoc." Sorry.
"This wine captures the
essence of Southern France." So
that's in the plastic cup.
So the question for you is
just to think about what
you're tasting when you
taste these two, and
which one you prefer.
So go ahead.
Take a sip.
Maybe let the first one kind of
sit around your mouth for a
minute and think about
what you're tasting.
And after you've had a chance
to taste the first one, and
kind of make your mental notes
about it, taste the second one
and think about what
you're tasting.
Out of curiosity here, can
I get a show of hands?
And think about which
one you prefer.
Can I get a show of hands of
people who preferred the first
one in the white cup?
So I'm going to count
these out.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8,
9, 10, 11, 12, 13,
14, 15, 16, 17, 18.
And who preferred
the second one?
The plastic cup?
Raise your hands high.
Don't be shy.
So 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8, 9, 10, 11.
So what was it?
18 to 11?
OK, I've been horribly rude.
I've tricked you all.
A few hands are [INAUDIBLE].
Who here couldn't make
their mind up?
One person.
Oh, that is sad.
So Chef Bill very kindly--
it was my fault.
He followed my instructions.
I told him to take the two
bottles of wine, pour them
into a bucket, mix them,
and then pour them
back into the bottles.
So the two cups are identical.
So what just happened, besides
a whole bunch of really smart
Google engineers--
yeah, fell for it.
Sorry.
I'm an engineer, too.
I fell for it, too, the first
time this was done to me.
AUDIENCE: Smell them.
JEFF POTTER: You can smell
the paper cup.
I have done this with plastic
cups that are red and blue,
where there's no smell
difference.
And people were like, oh,
but things that are
in red taste better.
There's certainly something
going on here.
Probably the best explanation
I have is actually something
called taste adaptation.
Your first taste of something
influences what you taste
after that.
So your perception of it is also
not just based on what
you think going in based on how
I read it, but the fact
that you hadn't had any
wine before that.
So if you're thinking about
sensory analysis, it's
actually a lot like thinking
about data
analysis in any context.
You have to do a proper, good,
controlled experiment.
In the case of something like
this, what would normally be
done is something called a
triangle test, where you're
given three samples where one
is different and two are the
same, and you're asked to pick
out which one of these is
different from the other two.
At that point, you can do
some pretty good stats.
But if you're just given two
samples and say which one do
you like better, it's really
hard to figure out, because
you don't really know based even
on just taste adaptation
or whatever else is going on
that day why you picked one
over the other.
You can't really describe it
in any sort of quantitative
way that's useful.
So I find that it's kind of a
fun thing to do to get people
to think about what you're
sensing, what you're tasting,
how much of it's actually in the
food, and how much of it
is in your perception
of the food.
And there's a whole bunch of
studies that have looked at
red wine versus white wine, or
people who are told that
they're given a white wine and
a red wine, and the red wine
is actually the white one
that's been dyed red.
And this study actually comes up
time after time, and it's a
fascinating one.
Not for the reason that you
might think here in terms of,
hey, you're being fooled, that
it's white wine versus red
wine, but the participants are
asked to describe the wine.
And it turns out that what they
found was that people
describe white wines with
different attitudes than they
describe red wines.
They actually will taste
them as different.
And I've done this.
You can blindfold people and
give them white wine versus
red wine, and unless you're out
to really trick them by
really carefully picking your
wines, you actually can really
tell white wine versus
red wines.
It's not that hard.
The tannins in red wine
are pretty distinct.
You will pick up on it.
But the way you describe the
wines, we seem to use color as
part of how we describe flavor,
which is really
fascinating, actually.
So let's go on to the
second one here.
What should we do?
Well, I guess I was talking
about the eggs.
So we'll go ahead and do
the sous vide egg.
You should all have a cup.
And I promise that's the
last trick, really.
I won't do any more tricks.
And I say that to everybody,
and then I do it again.
But really, that is
the last one.
So Chef Bill has kindly cooked
eggs at 63 degrees Celsius for
an hour, and that's what's
in these guys.
You saw the video earlier of
me cracking an egg on the
counter, and then basically, it
falling out of the shell.
So basically, just crack
it on your tray.
And feel free to
dump it into--
I'd probably dump it
into this cup.
But you'll get a sense of what
one of these eggs looks like.
And there's also some garlic
toast to go along with it, so
should you like-- kind
of an awesome sound.
The sound of dozens of Google
engineers cracking eggs.
So think about what you're
experiencing here.
I mean, you've got an egg where
the yolk is almost like
mayonnaise, where it's
kind of pliable.
You can move it around, but
it holds its shape.
The white itself has a couple
of different layers.
Eggs actually have about seven
layers in them, so one of the
outermost layers has more of a
certain protein that doesn't
set until a higher temperature,
which is why the
egg falls out of the shell
when cooked this way.
Maybe some salt and pepper would
be, if you were cooking
for a bunch of people.
But it's kind of neat to
actually experience an egg
that's been done in
a different way.
What do you guys think?
I got a thumbs up, and somebody
said it's great.
Another thumbs up.
So there are more of these eggs
cooking out in a water
bath out there.
You guys are welcome to poke at
it later, and kind of take
a look, and we'll stand around
and chat about it.
Then let's go on to the
third experiment.
This is a basic fun
taste test.
It's the sort of thing that I
wish someone had done with me
when I was in sixth grade,
because it was kind of cool to
do when I was in my 20s.
You'll see that there are 10
different cups in front of
you, and you also have post
it notes and a pen.
The challenge is to figure out
what those 10 different
ingredients are.
Now, I will say here if you have
any sort of allergy, you
should opt out, just
because there are
potential allergens here.
But if you guys want to poke
through them and write down
your guesses for
a few minutes--
and while we're doing that, I'd
be actually happy to take
questions on anything so far.
So feel free to basically
run through them.
The little cups aren't actually
laid out exactly the
same on everybody's tray,
so I would start with
the white cube ones.
There's two that are kind
of white and cube.
And work your way up a
line and down a line.
And when we go through them,
I'll try to keep it in order,
but you'll figure out if you've
got them mixed up.
So while you guys are tasting
stuff and writing down your
guesses, feel free to throw any
questions you've got at me
so far from all the various
temperatures.
And feel free to consult
your neighbors.
I see a very puzzled look
here in the front.
Which one are you looking at?
That one.
Oh.
That's usually people's
favorite.
It's really good.
We'll come back to this.
So he's referring to the
one that's a kind of
powdery black stuff.
He's saying, it's really good.
I promise, it's completely
legal.
It is not dirt.
At least, I wouldn't
characterize it as dirt.
Hey, hush there.
You might think that.
It might not be missing
anything.
That's the real catch.
That's actually a question
for Chef Bill.
Is it the whole product?
It is.
OK.
Yeah, no, it's not
missing anything.
So it's probably been enough
time you've probably got at
least a few of them written
down and guessed.
So let's go with
the first one.
These are the large
white squares.
Yeah, I'd have a hard time
actually guessing that.
So it's this one.
I don't know if you can see.
It's kind of the large
white cubes.
What did people guess
for this one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JEFF POTTER: The soft one.
Radishes, one person says.
OK.
Zucchini.
What else do we have?
Daikon.
Any other guesses?
Turnip?
Did anybody else guess turnip?
You've got to raise
your hands.
Like, seriously raise
So we've got, let's see--
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Radish is not the same as
turnip, unfortunately.
So six of you got it.
It is indeed turnip.
It's a little more bitter than
I thought turnip would be.
OK, let's go on to
the second one.
This is the smaller
white cubed stuff.
OK, jicama and radish.
What else do we have?
Watercress?
Daikon?
It is indeed jicama.
OK, so there's this kind
of white powdery stuff
that looks like that.
It's almost--
almonds, macadamia nuts,
what else do we have?
Walnuts?
Almonds?
So this is a fascinating
thing.
I'm going to suggest that you
taste this right now and get
the taste in your mouth.
I had the same thing
happen to me with a
completely different food.
It was hot dogs versus ham.
And at that point, what I was
tasting was very clearly one,
and then someone told me what
it was, and as soon as they
said it, the flavor was there.
It was really interesting.
This is actually hazelnut.
And as soon as you hear
that, it's like, yeah.
There's a flavor there, and
you can actually taste.
It takes maybe two or three
seconds in from when you put
it in your mouth, and then
suddenly, it's hazelnut.
OK, the green one.
Leaves of celery.
Basil, cilantro.
Who here tastes this
as Ivory soap?
One, two, anyone else?
Three?
AUDIENCE: As soon as I tasted
it, I knew what it was.
JEFF POTTER: You knew
what it was.
OK, so it's cilantro.
And cilantro is fascinating,
because about 11% of the
population, Julia Child actually
included, taste it
like Ivory soap.
So the three of you that taste
it like Ivory soap, if you
didn't know before, you now
know that you really don't
like cilantro.
You probably already
knew, I'm guessing.
And I've got to say, this is the
most green cilantro sample
I've ever seen.
And I actually asked Chef
Bill, is that natural?
He's like, yeah.
He blanched it, little bit of
salt water, and did an amazing
job with it.
So, I mean, I'd buy this.
OK, then there is this small
little piece of--
how would you describe that?
It just kind of looks like
a little smear of--
so I've got tamarind,
this one.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JEFF POTTER: Yeah.
You can almost pick
it up and--
AUDIENCE: It's a little like
beef jerky and [INAUDIBLE].
JEFF POTTER: Beef
jerky and soft.
Yeah.
Sun dried tomatoes?
Fish paste?
Raspberry fruit bar?
It's really sour, now that I've
eaten the whole thing.
It's tamarind paste.
Just tamarind.
OK, there's one that's got a
couple of cubes of this thing.
Any guesses?
I've got one person just
shaking his head.
Corn meal.
Say what?
Millet?
Oats?
It's actually polenta.
So whoever guessed corn
meal was pretty close.
I mean, I'd give it to you.
Chef Bill, can you remind me?
You said there was something
special about where the
polenta for this came from.
Red flint corn.
OK.
So you've got one that's
got little seeds in it.
Yep, that's caraway.
Chef and I were talking
beforehand, like, he was
wondering if he should
have ground them up.
And I was like, nah, people
won't necessarily know, but.
It's definitely got
a strong taste.
No mistaking it.
Then let's go for this one.
Almond butter, peanut butter,
cashew butter, sunflower
seeds, tahini.
It's sunflower seeds.
Now, maybe I should have
suggested you get the taste in
your mouth and then tell you,
but isn't that amazing?
It's like, you don't know it
beforehand, you have one
taste, and then you're
told what it is,
and it suddenly becomes--
OK, two more to go.
This guy.
Kind of the purpleish.
Cherry?
Did someone say banana?
Somebody's guessing currant.
Raspberry.
Blackberries.
It is blackberry.
Looks like blood?
Wow.
Hemoglobin.
I've clearly not been thinking
creatively enough.
Next time I'm here--
OK, the last one
in these little
cups, this black powder.
This black powder that somebody
said was really delicious.
Chocolate cake?
It is Oreo cookie.
This is Oreo cookie.
It's the whole cookie, cream
filling and all.
Yep, the whole thing.
Whole cookie.
Just straight blended.
Comes out like this.
The amazing thing is, most
people, when I do this taste
test, they will leave most
of the cups empty,
with food in them.
This cup will be empty, which
is a little scary, if you
think about it, because it's
the only thing in this list
that's actually completely
artificial in the sense that
it's not something you can go
out and pick or dig up.
It's engineered.
It's engineered for you to like
it, and it works, and
it's delicious, and it's
not so good for you in
the sense of health.
I mena, a little bit's fine,
but I wouldn't want to eat
that every day.
So hopefully, you learned
something about the way that
you are perceiving flavors
and tastes by not
knowing what they are.
And we didn't do any
tricks here.
We didn't dye anything.
There was no blindfold.
You actually had a lot of visual
clues about what you
were experiencing.
Imagine if you were blindfolded,
and imagine if
these things are completely
pureed, and you didn't have
anything but just odor, and
then after you smelled it,
were also given a taste
of it and were
allowed to guess again.
So even without that layer of
information removed, it's
still kind of fun, and
surprisingly difficult to
figure out what it
is you're eating.
Two down, two to go.
So let's go for this guy.
There's a little cup that's
got a strip of paper and a
peppermint candy.
This is a genetic test.
Some of you will taste this one
way, some of you will not
taste it that way.
Technically, I should tell
you it's a carcinogen.
It's a really small dosage.
It's fine.
But if you really get freaked
out by that, don't do it.
That's fine.
The peppermint candy is
for if you need it.
You'll know.
So the way this works is
basically, you just put it on
your tongue and see
what happens.
Whoa, look at all
the colors now.
What's it taste like?
AUDIENCE: Bitter.
JEFF POTTER: Bitter.
So if it tastes bitter to you,
you're probably going to want
the peppermint.
AUDIENCE: Is it aspirin?
JEFF POTTER: It's not aspirin.
So what's on here is
a compound called
phenylthiocarbamide.
PTC for short.
A chemist by the name of Arthur
Fox in the 1930s,
DuPont researcher, spilled this
on his lab bench, and he
didn't notice.
And one of his colleagues was
like, whoa, what's that really
bitter flavor?
This was way back in the
days before OSHA.
So Fox, like all good
researchers, started giving it
to people and seeing what
the reaction was.
And what he found is that some
people taste it as really
bitter, which I'm guessing
was you.
Who actually tasted this as
super bitter and wants to
punch me right now?
1, 2--
really?
That many?
Raise your hands high so I
can really get a count.
This is for science.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, 10, 11, 12.
AUDIENCE: How bitter?
JEFF POTTER: Like,
really bitter.
There's a middle ground where
it's bitter-ish, but
you don't hate me.
Great.
And who just had it taste
like wet news strip?
1, 2, 3, 4.
That's actually--
OK.
So the general population, just
on average, 25% taste it
as really bitter, 50% taste it
as moderately bitter, and 25%
taste it like me, like
it's a sheet of
newspaper or something.
Just tastes like nothing.
It turns out phenylthiocarbamide
doesn't
actually exist naturally, but
it's similar enough to
compounds that do occur
naturally that if you taste
this as bitter, you're going to
find things like nicotine
to be more bitter.
Caffeine will be more
bitter to you.
There's classic compounds in
green vegetables called
glucosolinates that will
taste more bitter.
So if you taste this as bitter,
you're less likely to
eat green veggies.
You're laughing here.
You had a question?
AUDIENCE: Is it related
to age at all?
JEFF POTTER: Is it
related to age?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JEFF POTTER: There's a
preference for bitterness that
we actually develop
as we get older.
Younger kids actually prefer
sweeter foods.
There's actually some
correlation with bone growth
and preference for
sweet stuff.
So if you've got kids,
and they say I want
desserts, it's science.
I need that.
But no, there's nothing
age related to--
this particular thing is called
super tasting, which is
kind of a misnomer.
It's just one particular genetic
discriminator that we
know of in taste.
But it does mean that different
people actually
taste some kind of foods
in different ways.
So if you think about what you
cook, if you think about, say,
Brussels sprouts, we use salt
to cancel out bitterness.
So if you have something that
tastes bitter to you, you can
put salt on it.
It actually literally barely
masks the bitterness.
If you taste something that's
more bitter than somebody
else, you're going to
put more salt on it.
So you're actually going
to oversalt it to their
preference.
So the idea of having a salt
shaker on your table is
actually not so crazy, because
some people are actually going
to taste some things as more
bitter than others.
Let's see.
The last thing we've got here,
and actually, I might invite
Chef Bill if he is up for it
to come up and describe a
little bit more about the
watermelon stuff we've got
going on here, if he
feels like it.
While he's coming up here,
you'll also see you've got two
small cups that have pieces of
beef, and he can actually tell
us the exact cut of muscle.
One of these is cooked
traditionally, and one of
these is cooked sous vide.
So this is really an opportunity
to kind of poke,
chew, taste, and see what you
think of the differences of
the two of them.
CHEF BILL: Yes, so the steak we
have here is teres major,
which is a muscle under
the shoulder group.
JEFF POTTER: Hold the
mic right up.
CHEF BILL: I'm sorry.
It's beef.
So the one that is a
lighter pink color,
we've cooked sous vide.
134 degrees for 24 hours.
Then just toasted it lightly on
the outside on the grill to
kind of give it that
grilled flavor.
What it should yield is a nice
tender result, but kind of
like Jeff was talking about
before, you don't get that
bull's eye effect.
You don't get the different
layers of color change.
We've got one solid temperature
all the way
throughout.
So that meat is just the same
from the outside to the
inside, and the only thing we've
done is just grilled the
outside a little bit.
JEFF POTTER: The flavor of
both of them is amazing.
I'm noticing that the one that's
sous vide cooked is
definitely more tender.
I mean, just biting into it
and kind of tugging it.
I mean, we can get a little
more scientific and get a
spring loaded clamp and start
tearing it apart, but--
CHEF BILL: Right.
You're doing a good job
with the science.
There's the collagen factor,
we were talking
about before as well.
The longer we're letting that
go, kind of like the short
ribs, it gets to a point.
If you taste the other one, it's
gotten to a point quicker
where you can eat it, like you
were saying, because we've
just done it on the grill.
We brought it up to the exact
same temperature inside.
But you can see how the color's
changed all the way through.
And it's oxidized
a little bit.
It's been sitting
out in the room.
It was just a little bit pink in
the center for our 134, and
then it got darker on the way
out, because it was cooked all
the way on the grill.
Again, done enough to eat, but
not necessarily as tender as
something that's cooked at that
optimal temperature for a
long period of time.
And the watermelon.
JEFF POTTER: Yes, and
the watermelon.
Actually, let's grab the
pack behind you.
So this is--
we were emailing back and forth
before I showed up here,
and kind of thinking of what
are some fun things that we
might be able to show you that
are done, tools and techniques
that the pros have that are
actually really difficult to
do at home?
And compressed watermelon
definitely is.
I actually tried driving
over slices of
watermelon with a car.
It doesn't work.
CHEF BILL: Jeez, you are hacking
things up, aren't you?
JEFF POTTER: Well, I didn't have
one of your really handy
ultra-vacs.
CHEF BILL: I never even
thought about that.
It's a good idea.
JEFF POTTER: It's pressure,
but it's the wrong kind.
So I don't suggest driving
over watermelons.
Doesn't work out so well.
CHEF BILL: So, yeah.
So the darker one is the one
that we've compressed like
this in our vacuum
sealer machine.
What we do then is we're drawing
the oxygen out of the
bag itself and away from the
product, and atmospheric
pressure, when we seal the
bag, will compress it.
We've gone at 100% vacuum.
So this has taken all
of the oxygen out.
And this is what it looks
like before we cut it.
JEFF POTTER: How thick
was this before?
So right now it's maybe--
CHEF BILL: That's the
same thickness.
That's the great thing.
We're just drawing out the
oxygen and really compressing
around the outside.
The atmosphere is now
pressing on it.
You can feel that.
We can pass it around.
JEFF POTTER: Yeah, we'll
pass it around for--
It's kind of cool.
I mean, I want one
of those at home.
CHEF BILL: It is.
So you see it's changed
the composition and
the texture a bit.
It's burst all the cells inside,
all the oxygen's drawn
out, but yet, you can
still handle it.
You can still cut it.
It's still the same
shape and size.
Some say that it gets a
little bit sweeter.
I don't know if that's the
color perception thing.
I find that it does.
It'll make fruit that's
not quite ripe
a little bit sweeter.
But just kind of fun.
It's a technique we use
around here a lot.
It just really draws
your eye to it.
The traditional one tastes
delicious as well, but you'll
notice it's got a lot
more water inside.
It's still got all that oxygen,
so it's a very, very
pale pink instead of
that dark red.
JEFF POTTER: Awesome.
Thank you.
CHEF BILL: Thank you.
Pleasure.
JEFF POTTER: So I think we've
gone through all the
experiments that we had
set up for today.
I'm totally happy to hang out,
answer questions, eat lunch.
Hopefully it's been fun for you
guys just to think about
what's going on in food from a
little bit of a science point
of view, and then think about
the perception of food.
And thank you for
having me here.
So with that, questions,
and whatever else.
AUDIENCE: How did you go about
learning all of these things?
Because I'm guessing you didn't
know all these things
at the beginning, so you
decided that you became
interested in food and kind
of different models.
And how did you go about
discovering all of this stuff?
I mean, I like to cook,
and like I've never
seen any of, like--
I mean, some of this stuff I've
heard of before, but it
doesn't seem like there's a
wealth of information out
there about this.
JEFF POTTER: I have a one word
answer, and it's really funny.
AUDIENCE: Google?
JEFF POTTER: Google.
Thank you.
A lot of it comes down to
sitting down and trying to
understand what's going on.
It might be something as
simple-- and actually, I
Tweeted out a photo that
someone else took
earlier this week.
They had made eight different
chocolate chip cookies.
Eggs and chocolate
chip cookies.
They're just easy things
to talk about.
They had made batches of cookies
with too much flour,
or too much brown sugar versus
white sugar, and they just had
a visual chart of what happens
if you make cookies with too
much of any particular
variable thrown off?
And you just look at it, and
it's a visual proof.
You look and go, oh righ.t my
cookie matches that one.
I now know I'm doing
that bit wrong.
It's a thousand little details
like that you just try to pick
up and start understanding
what's going on.
For me, my background
is computer science.
It's not food science.
But there's still that science
curiosity in there.
So I approached it with all
the same questions that
anybody who's not professionally
trained would
approach it with.
So I don't know, chocolate.
Chocolate's actually
really fascinating.
Chocolate's incredibly
complicated,
and people love chocolate.
There's six different point
polymorphs of the cocoa fats
in chocolate, and they melt
at various temperatures.
You start unwrapping this and
trying to understand what it
means to temper chocolate, and
you look up stuff, and you
start saying, oh, well, then
this makes sense, but now I
have this question.
OK, I answered that question,
but then I have this question.
And it just kind of becomes
this journey of trying to
figure out how does
this thing work?
How does this thing called,
whether it's making a
chocolate chip cookie or cooking
a perfect steak.
Like, each little step actually
makes sense, but you
really have to sit down
and say, what do I
think is going on here?
And do either some research on
it and try to figure out what
other people have
found, or really
just go into the kitchen.
I mean, a really good
thermometer and a notepad will
actually get you a lot of
data really easily.
So yeah.
Was that a question or a
scratch of the head?
It's a question.
OK.
Both.
And I'm going to grab one thing
out of my bag while you
do the mic.
AUDIENCE: So I recently
discovered something called
the miracle berry.
JEFF POTTER: Yes, miraculin.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and I was
curious if you've used it in
the kitchen.
JEFF POTTER: Yeah, so the
name is definitely--
they had good PR, right?
Calling something a miracle
berry is like,
oh, that sounds amazing.
There's a compound in a
particular berry that's an
African bush.
The compound's called
miraculin.
It binds to receptors on your
tongue, and it causes sour
things to register as sweet.
So if you actually just take a
miracle berry and chomp down
on it and get some of the juices
is on your tongue, they
make tablets which are actually
a little bit easier
to work with, because you
don't have to deal with
shipping berries that go bad,
and tablets, whatever.
So you can then put the
miraculin on your tongue and
then bite into a lemon, and
it will taste sweet.
I've had friends that had roast
beef, and they said it
tasted like honey glazed roast
beef, like in a sandwich.
It basically is kind of a neat
trick, if that makes sense.
It's kind of like the cilantro
tasting like
Ivory soap to you.
There are things in taste and
how we perceive things that,
genetically, are, how to put--
kind of cool.
I don't know if miraculin is
anything more than kind of a
fun thing to do once.
I mean, it's neat to do.
I encourage you to have a little
miracle berry party, as
they kind of jokingly
call them.
Go grab some foods.
There's actually a page
in the book--
I can send it to you via email--
that has a bunch of
foods that are just fun
to try it with.
It also alters a little bit of
things-- like Tabasco sauce,
for example, will taste oddly
sweet, and there's
some other fun ones.
Keep in mind, thought, that it
doesn't actually the pH of
whatever you're eating.
So if you just sat down and ate
two whole lemons, you're
probably not going
to be too happy.
This isn't going to change that,
so don't go off and go,
oh, lemon, lemon, lemon,
because it's
not going to be fun.
But yeah, it's a neat
thing to do.
AUDIENCE: So with the natural
food movement, and kind of
moving toward organicness and
other things like that, have
you, going away from that,
had pushback from anyone?
Using your scientific method in
a traditional industry, is
it odd for people to see
this kind of stuff?
JEFF POTTER: No, I don't
really think so.
I mean, there's a difference
between--
look, science really is about
building models and
understanding how
things work, and
that's extremely important.
Especially important
in organic farming.
You have to understand how
the system is working.
So if you're looking
at anything like--
take Polyface farm.
You have to really understand,
if you're in that environment,
how the ecosystem is working.
And the science is
fundamental and
paramount for that to work.
It is a tool.
Whether you take that tool and
use it to figure out how to
make a sustainable organic
system, or if you take it to
go and figure out how to make
black powder from the sample,
one of these things might be
good for you and one of these
things might not be so good,
depending on how
much you eat of it.
But from a science point
of view, no.
There's really zero
tension there.
I mean, you certainly get into
dogma and beliefs about, oh,
this is what you're
supposed to do.
This is what's really
good for you.
I believe this.
And my response to that is,
well, what's your model?
Let's see the data.
And if the data supports
it, then hey, we've
both learned something.
If the data disproves it, well,
then I might challenge
the person to think about why
are they believing that?
And that's, shall we
say, outside the
domain of food science.
PRESENTER: OK, no
more questions.
So thank you, Jeff, very
much for coming.
JEFF POTTER: My pleasure.
Thanks.